inciso se encuentra el valor promedio de
f en el intervalo menos 11 así que el
valor pone de una función el valor por
una función
escribamos promedio va a ser igual
a la integral de menos 1 a 1 de fx de x
dividido entre el cambio en x dividido
entre el cambio el perdón es la integral
de menos 1 a 1 de fx de x dividido entre
el cambio en x en este caso
1 - menos 1
lo cual es igual a un medio del integral
de menos 1 a 1 de fx pero en este caso
la función fx es una función definida en
dos partes la primera parte es de menos
10 de fx de x + y deja de ponerlo de
esta manera para no tener que arrastrar
un medio guapo en el mejor corchete más
la integral de 0 a 1 de fx de x
y la razón por la que separa esta
integral es porque esta función es
distinta para estas dos partes en una
función definida por partes tiene un
valor para x menor o igual a 0 y un
valor distinto para x mayor a 0 por eso
le hemos separado en dos partes
así es que esto es igual a un medio del
integral y luego a poner en estos
grandes corchetes el integral de esto de
aquí que es la integral de menos 10 de
fx de x y fx entre menos 10 es uno menos
20 de x de x
más la integral de 0 a 1 de fx y entre 0
y 1 la función fx es que a la menos 4 x
al menos 4 x de x
haremos las dos integrales
entonces esto va a ser igual
y medio abro aquí ese gran corchete y
déjame déjame ajustar la pluma no está
gastando dejan sacar un poco más ahora
sí ya de regreso a la chamba así es que
la anti derivada de 1 menos 12 de x la
antigüedad de 1 es x
aquilanti de uno y la anti derivada de
menos dos x la anterior edades seno de x
es menos de x que iba de menos 0 x es
coseno de x así es que esto es 2 coseno
de x y lo podemos verificar derivamos 2
coseno de xy tenemos menos dos seno de x
esta es la primera parte y esto de menos
1 a 0
más la anti derivada de al menos 4 x la
anterior de al menos 4 x es
menos
al menos 4 x sobre 4 si esto hubiera
sido real a equis entonces la entidad
habría sido a la x tal cual pero aquí
tenemos sea la menos 4 x decir que si no
sufrimos derivado ya la menos 4x
tendríamos por regla la cadena menos 4
de la menos 4x pero sólo tenemos el
término de la menos 4x nos hace falta la
derivada de menos 4x que sería menos 4
pero obviamente aquí no tenemos término
menos 4 por lo cual tenemos que dividir
entre menos 4 para obtener la antidiva
'como menos de al menos 4 x entre 4 otra
manera de ver esto es hagamos esta
integral por fuera la integral de al
menos 4 x tx y de hecho necesitamos
integral de 0 a 1 de al menos 4 x de x
y esto lo vamos a completar de la
siguiente manera necesitamos la derivada
de menos 4x es decir menos 4 y para que
no se altere esta expresión está 2 x
menos un cuarto o divide entre menos 4
aquí tenemos menos 4 x menos un cuarto
estamos multiplicando por 1 esta
expresión de tal manera que no se altera
y aquí tenemos ya menos 4 de la menos 4x
que es la derivada de a la menos 4 x por
lo cual la anti derivada de menos 4 de
la menos 4x es que a la menos 4 x y con
este menos un cuarto que tenemos afuera
tenemos menos a la menos 4 x entre 4 por
cualquier de las dos formas obtenemos lo
mismo espero que esto te ha quedado
claro ya habíamos visto esto en vídeos
previos de cálculo
esto lo evaluamos entre 0 y 1
entre 0 y 1 y cerramos corchetes y que
tenemos ahora
así es que esto es igual a un medio
abrimos corchetes
y si evaluamos x2 coseno de x en cero
tenemos 02 coseno de 0 coseno de 0 1
entonces evaluado en 0 obtenemos 2 menos
evaluado en el límite inferior de valor
al menos 1 sería menos 12 coseno de
menos 12 kos seno de menos 1 así es que
todo esto de aquí nos da este resultado
de acá
más vamos a evaluar esta expresión
sería menos
al menos 4 x evaluado en 1 sería menos
de al menos 4
- 4 x 1 - 4 - al menos 4 sobre 4 menos
a la menos cuatro por cero sería menos
a la 0 4 por 0 0 sería menos sea la 0 de
hecho menos sea la 0 es uno menos 1
sobre 4 y aquí cerramos el corchete para
indicar que esto está multiplicado por
un medio y ahora sólo nos queda
simplificar así es que esto es igual a
un medio que multiplica dejamos a otro
color aquí tenemos aquí un nuevo color
entonces esto es igual a 2 - menos 12
menos -1 estrés
y este signo menos que está afectando al
menos uno también afecta a este más dos
coseno de menos 1 es decir 3 - 2 coseno
de menos 1
más
más bien tendría que poner menos y al
menos 4 sobre 4 y menos menos un cuarto
sería más 14 y aquí también cerramos
corchetes y aquí tenemos aún una
simplificación que hacer este 3 y este
un cuarto lo sumamos sería el 12 cuartos
sumado es un cuarto esto va a ser 13
cuartos menos 2 coseno 2 coseno de menos
1 - al menos 4 sobre 4
y todo esto multiplicado por un medio y
no es la más bonita o elegante respuesta
pero esta es nuestra respuesta es el
valor por medio la función sobre el
intervalo